hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to growing my grandpa do you
remember discover my body
you've discovered the injection site
and I'm gonna do that now yes
I'm so happy discover my body was gained
by James
you guy may discover
my body was an interesting horror
experience where you were quite
literally using technology to discover
someone's body it's just as disturbing
as it sounds but not in the way that you
imagine this is another game from the
same developer called growing my grandpa
equally disturbing title and I imagine
equally disturbing uh mechanisms either
tutorial regarding the basic game
mechanics
a good
I I think I think I I think I'm gonna go
with no
I'm gonna figure it out
I regret it week one oh God no I
wondered what have I done
I excused Adrian during music class
today and spoke with her about a recent
string of demerits it was our first time
meeting outside of our quarterly
evaluations and I believe it went well I
can certainly understand Mrs Richardson
classroom's observation concerning
Adrian's emotional state she was of
course intensely shy when we first met
as I understand it she is similarly
withdrawn in her classroom activities
and only speaks her acts when she
absolutely must some things she simply
will not do instead of participating in
mandatory group activities she will sit
alone and accept that she will receive a
demerit before the meeting I read Mrs
Richardson's parent-teacher report which
allowed me to estimate some of Adrian's
home life the parents are well educated
and come from a prestigious background
but they lack time to properly nurture
Adrian she is often alone and when she
is not the parents seem to understand
the importance of warmth and affirmation
when dealing with someone so young
having two parents of this reserved an
icy temperament exacts an inhibition in
the child the child's imagination is
subdued but only ostensibly for it
eventually Finds Its way into regular
life I surmise that I would be able to
reach out to Adrian by way of
Make-Believe
that is is that Adrian why does Adrian
look like the guy from the room how are
you liking your new house you told me
you used to live close by but it can
still be a big adjustment a new room a
new school do you like the decoration
that I put in the place my slanted Apple
my wardrobe the one grandfather clock
sitting way in the shadows the empty
void of nothingness
Adrian this is built to make you
comfortable
okay the basement I like that the
basement yeah well there's a lot of cool
stuff mom and dad sent me down there
your mom and dad made you go yeah but
there's a lot of cool stuff well that's
not why they send me down there though
why do they send you down there
fighting they were fighting shouting I
came in to help and they shouted at me
they said go clean up downstairs so I
went
that sounds tough do they fight a lot no
well hey uh it's all right Adrian maybe
you can tell me more about this basement
that sounds creepy and dark just like my
room here
because they have a grandfather clock in
the basement okay well it was weird at
first the stuff down there
but cool I found something living sort
of
that's very interesting Adrian please
tell me more I don't actually want to
know more about that by indulging her in
her fantasies and stories I was able to
glean more of an understanding of
Adrian's anxiety surrounding your home
and parents the symbols of Adrian's
story seem to carry their own traumatic
weight and her exploration of the
basement may very well be a vehicle for
the conveyance of her anxiety whatever
might come of her next meeting whether
she will engage in similar make-believe
I will set down her story here
Adrian's Story begins with her delving
into the basement with a trash
receptacle and a glow and the goal of
cleaning up that's my goal I'm gonna
clean up and then I'm gonna grow my
grandpa easy peasy she discovered one of
the walls was covered in plastic bags
she went to investigate an intent on
tearing away whatever they covered oh
I'm in the basement
well that was awfully so I didn't uh
trash bags
[Music]
ah what am I grabbing what am I what am
I grabbing it please tell me these
aren't centipedes and they're just like
pieces of paper something
upon removing the plastic trash bags
from the wall she noticed their interior
lining was
covered in glass like a window I offered
no she said like a mirror oh reflecting
inwards towards the animal they
what wait and animal I gently asked her
what exactly this animal was here's
where the material reality of the story
took a turn for the explicitly fantastic
and imaginary oh my God
[Music]
oh that made me like viscerally
uncomfortable
which is a trademark of James's style
upon her discovery of it at her gaze
grew or extended its shaggy-haired self
hair like the fur of a dog I offered no
she said maybe I should just stop
offering suggestions not the fur of a
dog nor the hair on her head
it grew outwards towards her the
animal's hair reaching out it was hard
standing almost straight like the hair
on a brush a bristle I offered she said
yes
she was very afraid at first but then
very curious I'm just afraid I don't
want to touch it I asked her what else
was in the room more things hidden away
she said things of Grandpa's it well as
well
first she found a hidden passage under
the stairs inside were strange Dolls
magic objects naked faceless figures
naked faceless figures
all of these are very strange I heard
these cryptic utterances and merely
nodded so yeah that's all I can do in
order to keep the game of Make-Believe
going I only press for details where I
thought necessary The Faceless dolls
could be a simple metaphor for the
anonymity she feels in her own home the
hidden passage I am unsure of what to
make of that the revealing of the
concealed seems to be thematic in Her
Fantasy the door Under the Stairs is but
one example are you saying this is all
fancy I I have a funny feeling
[Music]
Gucci
[Laughter]
Gucci okay fine
okay yeah I don't know what that is
either yeah oh great crap okay the
darkness of the shadowy corner unnerves
you you cannot explore here without some
form of light you sure about that I'm
sure about that okay I don't know if I
want to explore there what
trash bile I'll take care of this
never mind no I won't
all right no I won't oh of course
ah yes now let's just take the weird
blue once you remove the panel and found
the magic hidden passageway she was very
specific about what she took
she found a magic book a magic doll a
photo of her late Grandpa and Magic glue
Hi how are you doing good to see you
mind if I step in uh Jessica take this
doll
[Music]
I hate this doll a slouching doll its
material is rough and coarse
hey
how you doing what's up hey guys it's me
Markiplier oh boy yeah search the clock
oh my God touch the magic book I found
it guys
wow the magic spell
there's so much trash hope the uh
faceless naked mannequins aren't staring
at me as I work all clean this space
will not be dirty again until next week
who's making it dirty what is this oh
God Grandpa Grandpa no oh no read no the
reverse uh good luck on your trip to the
Euros stay warm
order the Euros what are the Euros Lexi
and what are the Euros put the Euros in
way too big texts on screen
okay that's the Euros
glue all-purpose glue
but Magic
[Music]
Eurasian step Shamanism and the fusiform
gyrus an interdisciplinary study in
sympathetic magic a dissertation Jacob
Hart
oh my God uh relating to Magic and
magiko religious practices
folk charms or love spells
higiographs uh Kazar kaganate
what am I am I supposed to memorize is
this story important
uh uh uh Angel Heaven of need Heaven of
needles angel of needles was best known
kept best by shamanic Keepers or Wards
who suffer from face blindness
prosopagnosia whether by bird okay okay
it's extremely effective but terribly
dangerous so much oh okay okay this is
probably really important uh oh [ __ ]
wait no how do I
okay Lexi and you're gonna have to do
something for me you're gonna have to
just take like really small Snippets of
that and you're gonna put it in a really
creepy Texas we can make it really
ambionic and uh spooky this makes us the
magical religious meaning
subject of this dissertation will reside
I will outline further and then analyze
the historical sources I mentioned
previously then I will go into the
Neurology of Mystic and magical
religious experiences
he claims have been passed down through
his extended family for Generations I
interrupted to ask what she did with
these magical mysterious materials
grow Grandpa she explained plainly
and then without missing a beat she
continued on with her story while I have
no questions
that's self-explanatory nothing further
needed here feeling this was a potent
symbol I stopped her again to ask what
she meant someone puzzled I did not
understand immediately she explained
slowly Grandpa lives in the cage in the
other room the cage behind the door they
grew people in the cage
I don't know how you can make it any
clearer than that Grandpa lives in the
cage in the other room the cage is
behind the door
that's the cage they grew people in come
on it's basic it's basic maggiocentric
Alchemy whatever it was I don't even
well hi
hello hi how you doing
Gucci
what a wet willy
okay well hate that am I done here
door
door
you were home
oh a note great a hastily written note
ah I have repeatedly called your homes
to no avail and so I am forced to leave
this here for you all I found William
sitting in the corner of the enclosure
area seemingly severely concussed
Whiskers was gone and none of its usual
hiding places I immediately suspected
is that whiskers
[Music]
screws under the trash pile the project
zest must be suspended for now I am
leaving up the usual mirrored coverings
we use to keep the anthropoid
anthropoietic void sealed
I've done my best to lock up everything
on such short notice it is a hasty fix
but it will require some time to find a
more permanent remedy I am honestly
hoping you do not find this notice I
intend to lock a house down too I intend
to race off to you to retrieve your
lockbox keys do not worry about
William's key it and the rest of his
equipment is almost certainly deep
within whiskers now
I pray you do not enter this room no
matter how men may appear William cannot
be helped and his only being kept alive
as a means of continuing predation on
the rest of us I will say once again no
matter what state you may encounter
William in he cannot be helped I have
sympathy for the young man I truly do
but I found on his person several photos
of his late sister which would imply
certain risks he knew he was taking
[Music]
our excellent research materials have
now become possible liabilities either
criminal or professional in nature so I
have stash him away I believe I let you
all know how I might do this if we were
ever to experience in events such as
this I hope you all remember what I told
you so long then Dr H H stands for hot
so oh
what is
what is this regarding growth every time
whiskers regenerates and leave dormancy
it is to be logged as a new propagation
the sample's bodily existence cannot be
illegible I.E a part of cannot can be
cut from the hole so there can only be
one living propagation propagations are
to be terminated after five weeks any
further development Dr Hart the age
stood for heart termination procedure
will be posted and welcome you look
forward to
okay I'm reading these backwards all
right read now for the sake of the
University policy and the health of a
future career you hope to have abide am
I to understand hold on pause pause time
out time out time time time the thing
next to me is whiskers
and what you're telling me in these
notes is the thing next to me is a hyper
lethal organism that is trying to
be a predator to us and me in this
basement where I am
so my objectives are as follows clean
the basement grow my grandpa not die to
the anthropoidic void trying to kill me
called whiskers easy couldn't be simpler
[Music]
it must not be left unattended
anthropoidal shells I don't know what
that means
oh God
what did that happen I meant to that was
probably really important information
that I didn't get to read why is it
continue left Mount Read now okay ritual
Behavior with the sample the precise
mechanism for the exchange of symbols
and Gifts required for requested desires
yield is not known and even the
anecdotal counter Stacks are end in
violent death I have a missing some
crucial information so you're telling me
you are a deadly creature
are you a deadly creature gucci gucci
gucci gucci are you going to kill me
take that wet willy all right how do I
enter I will enter Beyond the Door in
the room the cage was hidden concealed
in another cloak of inward facing
mirrors
well time to fix that a hidden cage
lined with mirrors it is strange almost
poetic the elaborate fantasy of
self-reflection concealment con
captivity
yeah that
don't mind me good thing I have this
trash can
at the cage she finally cast her
Belle
but it was confusing she confided it at
first she took the photo or she took the
magic doll the magic glue in the photo
of her Grandpa and she combined them and
she wished very hard I can only assume
in this fantasy that next her wish would
come true and what's child's story would
it not
I'm guessing this ain't a fantasy
peculiar human representation
particular human representation generic
human figure
glued together
a tangible symbol of intention and
desire
she put grandpa in the cage assuming
what that was part of the ritual she was
not clear on how it worked I don't think
that cage is going to hold that thing if
that does come alive then become Grandpa
what precise instruction she could glean
from her grandfather's magic book was
complicated by a reading comprehension
stupid she wished with all her heart and
then she told me she waited a while for
something anything to happen and after
that time she began to cry I cried
really hard she said I wanted Grandpa to
be back I wanted my parents to stop
being so mean and it heard me it heard
me wish for Grandpa to come back for my
parents to be different I could feel it
through the walls and it felt me through
the air
I asked her exactly what she meant she
could only repeat what what she said by
this time lunch was almost over I said
goodbye to Adrian and she left to rejoin
her class
I was left to consider my our
conversation I believe the storytelling
strategy I have employed was not
unfruitful but I must probe deeper if I
can although I can be sure of nothing I
interpret the Impressions I get May
begin to help me get an idea of the
right questions to ask I'm beginning to
think this isn't a story at all and
maybe this is actually happening but
that would be ridiculous and go against
everything of my scientific education
and teachings of which I have many
knowledge you acquired this week has
given you access to certain topics or
keywords you can discuss with Grandpa
[Music]
I think this one Grandpa emerges no I
don't want to but what if I don't
but what if I don't you've also gained
the following keyword
she picked a penis considered disgusting
this when Grandpa emerges no oh
I don't think I will why
want Grandpa to emerge just kind of said
I don't really want Grandpa to emerge
cut it like that I don't really want
Grandpa to emerge I met again with
Adrian in order to address her emotional
Outburst in the past few weeks it is our
second time meeting and while it is
standard practice we have multiple
sessions with the troubled student as I
assembled a report for the counseling
department I could not help but think as
we sat down in my office said Adrian
already seemed to show a remarkable
change in self-esteem and confidence and
perhaps my and Mrs Richardson's
estimation of Aruba that's emotionally
disturbed was erroneous the paralyzing
shyness and withdrawn attitude Adrian
possessed last week was not entirely
diminished but she seemed to hold
herself differently this week however
this only lasted as long as our
conversation pertained to initial
introductory pleasantries when I began
once again asking about her parents her
feeling regarding her new school in her
new home she quickly lost what new
confidence she had gathered up and
withdrew into herself again so once
again I partook in some collaborative
make-believe but this time I was aided
by the fact that I had managed to do
some research into Adrian's grandfather
and I had some insight into what she
might actually be finding in the
basement now this may be overstepping my
bounds some as a School counseling
caseworker but this was all in the
service of making Adrian comfortable and
happy in this learning environment in
any case I was able to dig up
information regarding the grandfather by
inquiring at the University in town not
that I make it a habit of sleuthing but
I had a suspicion the grandfather was a
professor there or at least some sort of
researcher due to the fact that the
newly constructed laboratory on campus I
drive by every day Bears his name in
Memorial
he was some sort of anthropologist or
linguist or neuroscientist I did not
have to dig that deep before the scope
of his work became dizzying and I ran up
against the limits of my undergraduate
education back to the Make-Believe
hello Tommy what is your grandpa like is
he a smart man is he uh what do you call
one of them big
[Music]
but I'm teaching him so he's grown a
good deal then you have been feeding him
well yeah he's getting bigger
but he has a lot of room in his cage
he's still behind the bars yeah well he
might be able to climb out eventually
but there's there's this vent in the
ceiling well perhaps if he climbs out I
can meet him someday yeah maybe but he's
not ready to leave he can't take care of
himself I have to feed him pick up after
him uh you store the food in your
lunchbox that's nice of you to share
he almost talk you can't speak with him
he doesn't he doesn't have a mouth sort
of but how do you feed him he has a
mouth on the outside on his shell or
stuff that's his skin I'm a little
confused
and terrified maybe you can go through a
typical day with your grandpa okay I
asked her how to to explain how exactly
she goes about growing her Grandpa and
Adrian began another Tale
according to Adrian in the week that
passed much had changed in the basement
good oh it's good well that's not good
the hairy thing that was here before is
gone just a blood stain remains
lunchbox is currently empty seek out
food for Grandpa
do I I should see Grandpa first
apparently I should
Grandpa
it was scary at first she said the way
he moved the way the doll's skin covered
him I wanted to interject this somehow
seemed inappropriate but I kept
listening
when I look at him she continued when I
think about him he grows and moves it's
like he's growing for me he's growing
bigger now I asked yes she said bigger
everything
oh hey grandpa oh grandpa don't do it
[Music]
this begins your actual growing part of
growing your grandpa beneath the doll's
burlap skin the follicles knit together
what resembles a proper person
your grandpa
uh whatever you say pal
you are in charge of its cognitive
development and diet until it is able to
sustain itself I don't want it to
sustain itself currently you're
observing Grandpa please click the arrow
back button below for a brief tutorial
of your duties as caretaker I might I
might need that here we can see a
variety of options regarding growing
your grandpa you will need to find it
food and learning material before you
can move on to next week
some foods will make Reba happy others
merely content some food will make
Grandpa disgusted to the point of nausea
learning material is also scattered
throughout the basement seek out
vocabulary cards intended to help teach
English in basic anthropoidic concept
formation what was that last part
Analyze That anthropotic concept
formation
okay
uh options highlight a related
navigating go to Grandpa we'll let you
perform all actions directly related to
Grandpa feeding teaching observing study
corner will let you go over any
documents you pick up as we go by it's a
good idea to learn about the work of the
people who last occupied this space
accessing the kitchen corner will let
you search for food in your old
refrigerator and prepare food for real
block if need be one final note take
care to explore the basement at your
leisure however due to the entropic
nature of clutter and trash different
weeks may allow you to find things you
had previously not discovered
what about trash
explore the basement
I'm going to explore the basement good
hey what do you mean pull the Scrolls
what's up
something appears to be growing from the
wall you take a closer look uh oh
[Music]
is that a smiley face I see on that I
see two two eyes at the top and a curve
of something that might be a smile that
is nice that is nice not nice
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
there we go that Markiplier fusses with
his hair
hair break is sponsored by this
[Music]
hey man a pulsating sack all right the
slimy membrane that it's that is its
skin seems to contain something I might
be able to open it with a blade
I might you know you know what
you right I might good God this is a lot
of trash
[Music]
thank you
what is it what was that sound I heard a
sound corroded battery this isn't really
food grandpa might eat it however
Linguistics module hello vocabulary card
teach Grandpa this word to read the
notes of past educators
oh [ __ ] I don't have a lighter over
there
well this is good this is all super good
I am uncomfortable cabinet slouching
under the weight of rot and refuse
well I'm here with the trash can so rod
and refuse is my job
[Music]
oh good blueberries it looks edible I
doubt that why would blueberries in a
wardrobe that was rotting and crushing
under its own weight grandpa might like
this he might or he might not who knows
top drawer this
foreign
[Music]
this in detail in the study Corner okay
I could probably see that note that I
missed read now before we begin he had
us all cover our faces completely and
earthenware pot was illegible and on the
inside as we stole brief glances at it
we could see the interior was inlaid
with mirrors the illegible gave it small
pieces of dough spoiled food chicken
feed keeping it content great the keeper
gestured towards a small bag worth of
food composted and told us to be careful
not to feed it any meat no meat I
understand I asked if the rotting food
was enough to sustain it how it might
get nutrients from any of this the
keeper regarded me seriously and said it
did not matter whether it was fed the
act of feeding itself was What mattered
the act of feeding flesh is another act
however he then gave me another series
of grave warnings regarding not keeping
any animal derived Foods near where I
might be keeping it interesting that is
probably very important information that
I should pay attention to
this is horrible
hate that
oh
interesting some kind of a key lock
there's two keyholes that I see nothing
else to there safety 1951 and no
markings on that one okay good great
love it and also I hated trash pile
examine something about the painting
looks strange oh something about that
painting nothing else in there let's
just let's just recap all the strange
things we've seen in the basement so far
weird hair regrowth closet full of
mannequins Under the Stairs Grandpa
Grandpa version two blueberries the
drawer full of doll heads
everything else that I've forgotten no
this seems weird all right okay
a folder full of radiographic images you
can examine this in detail later
I'm sure I can okay
fiberglass insulation this isn't really
food grandpa might eat it however
[Music]
okay
love me some wall cotton candy
like the way it makes my gums tingle
okay all right goodbye
another trash pile there's so many trash
Pals wastier smells particularly strong
right okay
a simple paper doll might be useful in
the construction of magic symbols okay
like that I'm just uncovering more trash
beneath the trash pile that I don't need
to clean I just worry about crumpled
paper that's all I care about all right
well grandpa I got some goodies for you
oh man I got goodies
whoo boy I got goodies I got goodies hi
Grandpa okay let's go to the study
corner
examine education look over the
documents okay orientation note I think
two did I accidentally skip over read
more
uh desirous yield
no I developing attachments to your
colleagues if you begin to suspect you
are developing attachments to your
colleagues contact me as soon as
possible
interesting however the speed at which
its desires yield is produced can be
dampened by several precautions what do
you mean desirous libidinal libidinal
libidden and emotional urges so don't
don't fall in love the objection
objectives I gotta clean up the trash
grow my grandpa that other thing that
was very important to my survival and
don't fall in love
not easy
um because I'm an educational posters
oh hello
[Music]
hello a set of procedures regarding
disposable interment read now the
researcher will seal off the enclosure
bars ensuring minimal gas leakage during
the later fumigation process and then
retrieve the burn barrel and place it in
the near enclosure allow at least 48
Hours of time where the current growth
cycle experiences no human related
stimuli do not enter the enclosure area
nor any part of the basement ideally you
will not be on the grounds at all after
48 hours two researchers will enter the
basement wearing their assigned mirror
mask mirror apron and powered air
purifying respirator the researcher will
use the vent system to fumigate the
enclosure area wait 30 minutes and then
use the fan system to ventilate the
enclosure keep the fans running during
steps three and four
I die oh man I don't know if I'm gonna
die uh I I feel like I'm Ill prepared to
grow my grandpa re-enter the enclosure
wearing your assigned mirror mask
complete dorm see if it is not in full
dormacy be sure that it's capacity to
act against you will be greatly
diminished with your assigned power
drills quickly remove any enclosure bars
needed to access the organism
put them aside for later reinstallation
but the organ
poser
grandma
put the organism into the burn barrel
incinerate the organism thoroughly wait
for any smoke to be properly cleared by
the fan system turn off the fans one
researcher will retrieve the nucleus
from the Ash and place it in the mirror
box the other researcher will sift
through the Ash and place any other
substantial which remains in The
Biohazard bin in the room outside of the
enclosure area the bin is locked for
safety purposes the code is 323245 got
it the researchers will fill out a
termination form and leave it for Dr
Hart
[Music]
oh I don't think I should talk to
Grandpa about that one
feel like that would be a bad idea Wham
no family togetherness here
falc Avenue one oh my goodness so much
to go through
oh what is that Donuts cashews it looks
edible grandpa might like this
that he might
coins
whoa
ah read now it was said to pass from one
family of Step people to another but
pressed on its ultimate origin somewhere
to the South coiled in a bowl covered in
incantations buried inside buried upside
down by a graveyard a common late
Antiquity demon trap the keeper an
elderly man in failing Health was ready
to expound on and on about the dangers
of the organism but when I asked more
pointed questions about the history of
its Exposition I was given Kurt
responses that had a way of circling
back to vague warnings almost as if he
really wanted to warn you about
something almost as if you should listen
listen to said warnings
okay cabinet too good so much trash
Grandpa that's Andy
oh there's there's something Secret at
the bottom here wait a minute boo oh oh
we got something false bottom false
bottom I'm gonna be happy about this you
remove the taped down fabric to reveal
the cabinet's wooden bottom
negotiate notation regarding sample
exoskeletons
each growth from a cycle does not
require a shell but you may find the
sample will often try to seize on
something somewhat flexible it can grow
into along with any desires yield it may
generate or else it will move from one
shell to the next as it outgrows him in
the small amount of time I have spent in
preparation I have noticed it tends
towards human forms however we should
keep a tight lid on the anthropoidic
seal in order to be cautious before we
begin to experiment with exposing it
long term to anthropoid stimuli
I don't know what any of that meant
to my colleagues I don't mean to be
overly severe in tone but Dr Hart's work
is very important in the material we are
working with is potentially very
dangerous
I will be handing out a copy of this
note as a reminder to everyone I'm not
trying to single any particular person
out we have all misconceptions about the
nature of this project from time to time
without out of the way here are some
things to keep in mind the active growth
must be thoroughly terminated via the
correct procedures at the very least
four weeks after dormancy is interrupted
well
what can you do
it doesn't matter what you've done or
haven't done regarding tests or
procedures or how much the anthropoidic
vacuum has been disrupted we are not
ready to go beyond four weeks at this
point a step-by-step guide determination
has been posted by the enclosure wall
please please please do not place the
educational posters over this posting
please please please
do not disrupt the anthropoiding vacuum
without Dr Hart's prior consultation in
any case of any emergency where the
vacuum is disrupted put on your
equipment and begin the lockdown
procedure make an extensive note of when
and how the breach has occurred if you
find the habitat empty page Dr heart
immediately but do not attempt to speak
with anyone else this thing can get very
smart I'm sure you're all aware of from
the stories we heard on our acquisition
trip the greatest caution should be used
when dealing with a potential aggressive
mimicry scenario please seek me out if
you have any more questions ah well I
aim to make it super smart good thing me
as a little girl this all goes over my
head because I can't read Medical
Imaging you slip the radiographic images
you found onto the machine's display do
I
power
oh my goodness oh my goodness
oh boy propagation number 21 day 19
after dormancy and vacuum broken yes
term notes in detail regarding the mimic
hypothesis a participant entered the
sealed chamber adjacent to whiskers
growth cycle 21 which had been freed
from the anthropoidic vacuum constructed
quite econom economically from plastic
and broken mirrors the first
propagation's original earthenware
vacuum was shattered during the move-in
between the two there was a semi-opaque
glass panel that allowed observation
both ways the human participant was
asked to think of someone in the popular
Consciousness fictional or no and
cogitated on their image personality
face impossible voice if possible Etc
our participant chose Jesus of Nazareth
and with weekly repeated exposures to
the participants imagings propagation
number 21 began forming what resembled
an anthropoid Nazarene in the fold of
its spines previous human-oriented tests
have always bore out a result that
whiskers would form an anthropoid team
member be it me or Dr Hart or Gerald or
we assumed it was merely mimicking one
of us Dr Hart has always contended the
desirous yield or the anthropoid
reproduction whiskers creates when in
contact with human beings has always
been based on the conception in relation
to the person through someone else
with this framework the desires yield is
not actually a replica of a person or if
it is it is only a replica of the
fiction of a person generated in the
mind of another so it's not actually
making replicas of people it's making
what people imagine that person to be
which is different with who the person
is probably
desires yield was not Jesus Christ but a
participant's image of Jesus assembled
from their religious upbringing
religious artwork depictions in popular
culture Etc this radiograph was taken
right before the destruction of the
growth cycle while Whiskers was rendered
unconscious via fumigation it seems like
every successive propagation the stem
cells in the organism work a little
faster but I'm not paranoid it's
technically deathless yes but we're
burning up whatever knowledge it's
gained from when we incinerated I don't
believe in magic just yet
well start believing this seems a little
magical you know if I had to guess oh
God what is this oh
taking the calling it with
whisk worse yeah whiskers is more
accurate needles are more like super
sensory follicles or spine nerve Nets
distributed blah blah blah things that I
don't understand x-ray spine dense
Optical Arrangements similar to compound
eyes so it sees through them
be happy to be it certainly is a robust
enough creature to inspire Marvel that
is not untinged with fear
great
I don't know what am I looking at what
am I looking at exposure to mammalian
forms part of a series of zoomorphic
influences LED further understanding
I write Samuel Laden the previous
oh God and yet at no time does it
function as the thing it becomes except
in the sense that it mimics it that is
to say when whiskers is removed from
dormancy and replicates a rabbit's
morphology it is not seeing from the
rabbit-sized nor smelling from the
rabbit's nose but pretending that it
doesn't doing a very good job at it so
it's using it as a puppet
that uh-huh strange thing about it was
that the subject of the image wasn't
found nowhere near the enclosure it's
almost like a piece of whiskers fell off
and scurried it
gross I feel like we've learned a lot
since then but at the time I remember
speaking about the morphology being
weird not really even resembling any
accident zoomorphic structure besides
maybe a cuttlefish then I happened to
open the thing up inside were all these
little dead amoeba-like things but they
all sort of looked like they had faces
faces that were just barely there after
I took the radiograph I gathered it up
and went to go throw it in the biohazard
bin as I walk by the bars of the
enclosure I could hear whiskers suddenly
going wild flopping around and grunting
excitedly could it have smelled the
Cuttlefish thing would it eat its own
production I guess it's technically
flesh this has beyond the scope of the
project but it could be that without the
stimulus of an active brain or more
specifically a healthy or active brain
capable of face recognition and theory
of Mind whiskers begins to pull whatever
it can from the limited data available
to it again this is not our focus at
this time but I left a note for Dr Hart
just in case he wanted to take a look
gross
okay well I I I've learned a lot but
also I didn't take a lot of that in so
uh
uh save I guess and kitchen
search upper fridge what lettuce okay
lower fridge banana I need to feed
grandma two acceptable Foods eat and
seek out things to feed grandpa I have a
battery
blueberries fiberglass cashews lettuce
very old lettuce leaf of lettuce it is
flaky and stiff a banana probably okay
blueberries with hard stone-like
exteriors I'm gonna go with the cashews
and the banana I guess I think I don't
know I don't know
soft fruit or vegetable
banen unappealing do I need an
unappealing item is this necessary
I'm confused if you put
a battery in the banana
it will be a super banana
conceal why
am I trying
to conceive
d
[Music]
the battery is concealed in the Browning
banana flesh
soft fruit or vegetable don't I have
I have lattice
blueberries
you something well I don't particularly
know what else to do so I'm going to go
to Grandpa
hi Grandpa you examine Grandpa noting
its movements respiration in general
mood
I don't like it because I don't know the
spindle's just the whiskers Grandpa
seems sort of sluggish and bored you get
the feeling it may be more content and
readily Cooperative once fed and taught
a word or two
okay
no response uh Grandpa would you like to
review the tutorial before you start you
will not be
this is a tutorial for feeding Grandpa
this brief material will go over the
basics of feeding Grandpa via induction
of your unprotected insula
grandpa has stimulated the production of
tooth enamel to mimic a human mouth it
will need to be fed through this in
order to properly learn and grow first
you will need to select an item for The
Lunchbox click the lunch box in the
bottom right of the corner the condos
that The Lunchbox will be displayed
select an item from The Lunchbox doing
so will fill your hand with this item
notice that any food could be put back
in The Lunchbox by clicking on The
Lunchbox with a full hand before Grandpa
can be fed he must judge the food by its
smell hover your hand above Grandpa's
olfactory bulbs if grandpa is pleased it
will allow you to feed it most Foods
grandpa will accept how for getting
grandpas to consume other things
requires some culinary deception when
Grandpa is willing to be fed hover your
hand over its mouth and click
grandpa will then consume the food
why do I need luck why would I need luck
you approached a small window set in the
jail bar
oh God no no
no click on Grandpa's nostril if
Grandpa's enticed by the smell click on
Grandpa
concealed battery
granted
unable to detect the unappealing item
will accept it for feeding
I don't know why I would give it the
other
foreign
although clinically consumed the meal
seems to be causing some indigestion why
would I do that
what what
plane Divine clearly disappointed by the
lack of substance gently locomotes back
to its favorite Corner what did I do
oh examines
good good
bye drive safe luck with the key you
found it pops open oh good who are you a
photo of your mother as a young woman
the recognition of this face kicks off a
Cascade of emotion and deep meaning
within your psyche
good
does this not does none
on that picture wasn't gonna rotate that
one for everybody what is happening
there
can I not have anything else
uh deep meaning my psyche is deep and
meaningful my deep meaningful psyche why
what do you mean I don't know why I did
that but I'm assuming that that was
important oh my God Grandpa I guess
anything else in your react
all right let's try the feeding a little
a little better this time
uh how would you like some cashews
foreign
okay let's try to give you some good
well Sade is hunger but that's all
finds it palatable
appears to have been sufficient
grunt is an appreciation the locomotes
towards its favorite corner
yay
yay
oh observe
seamsource sluggish and bored it seems
bigger than it was before you get the
feeling it'd be more content okay let's
teach Grandpa how about hello or Grandpa
card number one Yep this tutorial oh boy
okay the vocabulary word you picked will
appear in the top left corner in the
bottom right is a pentagon that is
divided up into eight sections each
section of the Pentagon will be
highlighted briefly
how do I know any of this
I just need to freak out for a little
bit you will control a small round icon
that sits above the pentacon by using
your mouse the ball is constrained to
the limits of the Pentagon
the goal is to keep the icon over the
highlighted area and move it around as
the area changes sections around the
Pentagon when you hold left click above
the correct highlighted area the icon
will start to vibrate along with the
simulated vocal cords and the current
letter of your word will begin to turn
red
keep holding over the highlighted
section to adjust your icon as it
changes place soon the letter will
become fully red after every letter
becomes red grandpa will proudly
pronounce the word you to you and it
will be considered learned teaching
Grandpa these words will accelerate its
cognitive development and lead to
further breakthroughs in general
intelligence teach word grandpa yes yes
I hi
okay
okay
oh
[Music]
I'm not seeing any red letter
is that the one
whoa oh wait I got something there
foreign
[Music]
there we go
who are
[Music]
okay so the the icon will
jiggle like that when it's ready is
horrible
no
no no dude
[Music]
oh
oh
deep within Grandpa's strange membranes
phonate confidently
yeah
good having completed the lesson you
take a look back at the vocabulary
module card in the notes there written
by administrators of the past
Grandpa your general pronunciation see
below we have done several sessions of
what we are calling familiar relation
simulation I and a co-research is hidden
chairs opposite the enclosure we are
wearing the usual masks and we begin to
act out a scene mostly through
improvisation that might roughly
resemble a kitchen table conversation
between an immediate family repeated
trials would reveal Although our
simulated conversations would
purposefully vague and unspecific
regarding persons or end identities we
would only address each other as brother
father sister etc etc it soon became
apparent the encoded information and
associations we unconsciously drawn upon
when hearing and speaking these words
was being picked up on by whiskers and
its sci-type field of reception
interpretation of brain mind event
somatic content my co-researcher William
noticed this in a simulation where
Whiskers was given a role as a sister
and he has a brother I was the father
whiskers began responding to certain
prompts with unusual specificity as well
as a general pattern of and Timber of
speech that continued with unusual
consistency as soon as the simulation
ended and we left the enclosure William
let me know the Whiskers was almost
certainly drawing from encoded memories
of his late sister mapping out exactly
what regions and centers of neural
activity are intercepted by the sci-type
field will take extensive neuroimaging
that we do not have at this site
currently we only have less precise
portable equipment however our
experiences so far are eerily in line
with folk knowledge and folk
explanations regarding the beans access
to desires and we can begin to infer it
has access to certain portions of the
limbic system and the ventral temporic
cortex you step away and store the
module
God this is great this is great this is
so good I feel so good about what I'm
doing is there like another uh how you
doing how you doing Grampy
sluggish and bored I
imagine you're gonna like the
I don't imagine you're gonna like the
fiberglass
no no no
I don't have any other food really I
think I missed out because the banana
probably would have been very good for
it but because I got the key I only have
an indifferent thing right so I'm gonna
feed it
one of the things I have I don't imagine
the blueberries would be very where'd my
blueberries go wait a minute where's my
blueberries didn't I have blueberries
are they not blueberries they might not
be blue oh no we like the blueberries I
already fed it the blueberries I'm an
idiot all right let's feed Grandma a
grandpa uh let's feed let's feed you
cashew is probably better I guess
there you go there you go pal
[Music]
okay
um
[Music]
okay feed Grandpa complete teach Grandpa
hello yes great grandpa it's time to
learn
[Music]
[Music]
hello
I'm not sure about that one um
that one wasn't quite as good
ah we already encountering some
difficulties as whiskers subjectivity is
so much determined by a diverse and
dynamic array of influences it attempts
to mimic the thoughts and desires it
passively intercepts and these
imitations go on to structure the basis
of its identity only later in whiskers
growth cycle does it begin to form an
identity that are coherent and capable
of resembling a sane rational human
being when engaged in conversation one
must imagine how hard it would be to
converse with someone who is not yet
oriented in one particular way towards
who or how they are because they might
have 20 different honest answers to
those questions all the mixed together
and muddled
because of this we have started with the
basics of conversation greetings
partings identifying one another forming
questions Etc it is fortunate whiskers
current growth 19 I believe has
developed a mostly accurate human Mouse
simulation hello was a bit of a
challenge in the previous growth as it
had failed to develop an adequate organ
to act as a human tongue great
and I guess I'm done for this week oh
boy more Grandpa growing next time well
um I I uh so uh I don't know if I'm
morally okay with everything but as far
as my objectives are going in the clean
the basement check growing Grandpa well
on its way I'll consider that a check
for this week uh not dying from that
horrible thing that I was talking about
before I'm still alive if that was the
objective and then number four
[Music]
the other one it sounds like this
mission complete so that'll do it for
this episode unless Grandpa comes after
me and decides to kill me and open me up
and I don't like observe
oh
no God no oh no it approaches the bars
it begins to unknit its skin oh dude
what have I done the inner Grandpa those
still enough fully formed is revealed it
made me fruitful to speak with if it
could respond
oh no oh
[Music]
ask about wish
okay I was about to end the week
with a great deal of effort Grandma
gurgles fragmented thoughts through its
ill-formed lips
of course it does
mother uh will father
new lives out of the air the dark spiny
filaments that make up the majority of
grandpas at Bugatti begin to oscillate
rapidly they are behind your eyes I can
taste it
great
happy about Grandpa shell
the great deal of effort skin my body
all human skin around me give more I
don't know if I want to grow more to fit
I don't know
biohazard been I don't know if I should
talk about this but I will
however fails to produce more than a wet
and frustrated sputtering noise
that makes sense goodbye
silently sends back into his shell
[Music]
I'll live for this episode
I am disturbed but I will continue
growing Grandpa and I will see what
Grandpa wants to uh talk about next week
in the next episode
thank you
say hi
anything else
[Music]